what is going on everybody welcome to
the third part of our Keltner channels
miniseries within our Python mathematics
and Finance indicators series where we
left off we were actually programming
the calendar channels and now we
actually want to graph them up and see
if we really did do our job right so
that's what we're going to be doing in
this video if you don't already have the
sample code you need to click the link
in the description I should take you to
this page and you want to click on
sample code with empty slot even though
we won't be using that empty slot then
just highlight it go all the way to the
bottom
copy it move that aside paste it into a
nice empty screen here and actually we
don't want to program it into here we
want it to be on the same axes as the
actual prices so scroll up a little bit
and we're going to put them right here
so under a x1 dot plot in this a v1 a v2
stuff just make it like a bunch of space
now what we want to do is come over here
wow that went missing
anyways come over here we'll get rid of
this and we really need to highlight and
copy everything up to ATR and so K take
that copy that color here paste it in
we need to indent this now twice oh my
bed wasn't even on the screen yeah good
stuff so I pasted it in right I
highlighted all of that stuff copied it
and pasted it in and then I'm just
highlighting it here and tab tab so it's
aligned so now we'll come down here and
now we actually want to plot like this
stuff right so once we've done that we
actually want to like show this like
these bands right so we're gonna say a
x1 dot plot and we're going to plot date
- SP : if you want to know why we're
doing that
check the turning stocks we do ul whoops
lowercase u o - SP : then we're gonna do
we're gonna plot this line as Xin line
and now what I'm going to go ahead and
do is copy and paste this three times
and it's a paste paste and this will be
our ml and this OB r ll lowered lap now
when we graph it well let's go ahead and
try and graph it and I'll work on
getting rid of some of the stuff that we
don't want so let's go ahead and run it
and see if it even runs suck two-ply
Starbucks please sir that's a lot of
output probably I guess it's a TR pride
printing something yep so I'm just going
to delete that from a TRS we don't have
to see that again
save and then also do print it out so
anyway we can see it there but as you
can probably see we've got like a lot of
freaking lines and it's because we've
got this 10 cent SMA and 50 SMA now if
you want to leave them there that's cool
that's you know whatever you want to do
but it gets kind of Oh a little busy so
either you would change the color maybe
or we can just get rid of those so what
I'm gonna go ahead and do is move this
aside we're gonna screw up a little bit
here's where they're plotted and I don't
think you have to get rid of those but
we have to get rid of the legend that
displays them so just do a ctrl F and
type in legend that should take you here
and just comment out this whole like
legend stuff and now when we graph this
at scratch Starbucks again it's just
that you know the the Keltner channels
now so if you wanted to clean it up
that's how you can hey you can go ahead
and do it so now we're plotting up our
color channels which i think are a
little bit better than the Bollinger
Bands
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this one
hopefully you learned something you're
interested in as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support in
the subscriptions and until the next
video